it just bugged me I thought are people
not gonna notice this
Terminator 2 coming back in theaters
which is so exciting because I mean
that's how I was introduced to Star Wars
so this could introduce a whole new
audience to the film I mean how does
that make you feel it's actually as a
filmmaker it's it's a it's a really fun
reward to know that an entire generation
later people who only know the film from
from video can now see it the way it was
meant to be seen I was very proud of the
70 millimeter release in in 1991 even
though 70 millimeter was already in
decline to me that was the gold standard
of cinema experience now we've gone so
far beyond that with you know 4k digital
conversion of the movie and then the 3d
conversion I mean it it not only it
looked better than it's ever looked plus
it's in 3d
yeah yeah um you know when like and then
I'm not comparing it to start with but
when I saw it I did not know that there
was so much that was changed in the
movie is there anything changed beyond
the conversion and kind of like is there
anything that you added to this release
yeah you know George Lucas I think he he
constantly had new ideas and wanted to
just kind of you know
punch punch up those films I sort of
felt like you know I've changed as an
artist I you know why would I want to
make second-guess myself from what I was
thinking back then and in 91 I actually
think the movie stands I didn't feel a
compelling need to change anything
editing wise other than to just get it
to the highest possible standard of
color and picture and
everything else that you know so we we
put all our energy into that we didn't
change it except for one thing there's
there's a shot that always bugged me
when the tow truck smashed it down into
the drainage canal and chases there the
kid on the bike the windshields fall out
when it jumps into the drainage canal
and then they're back in for their whole
whole rest of the sequence so we put
them back in so it doesn't fall out this
time but that's not really an editing
change that's really just just sort of
punching it continuity things it's just
bug people not gonna notice this and the
editor said nah nah goes by so fast
you'll never notice it but I always see
it so and but my justification is if I'd
had the digital technology to fix it
then I would have we just did
[Music]